when i was little and had my first real
relationship and i thought i was going
to grow up and get married to him and
was 100 certain that was gonna happen
and when we broke up i was just
distraught like unbelievably distraught
so what does happen with heartbreak is
it cortisol brain scans have shown is
that the same thing happens to our brain
when love is removed when the person we
love is removed from our life as happens
when heroin addicts withdrawing from
heroin if you think about it that way it
kind of explains it because if you would
think of a heroin addict who was
withdrawing they would steal they would
do all kinds of terrible things they
would never otherwise do but everyone
goes well they were an addict so that's
how desperate they were it explains the
level of desperation the level of change
and behavior it's the same mechanisms
that are getting activated when we're
heartbroken and it's that same level of
absolute desperation that you would see
happening for an addict